sup guys I'm Greg Alvin I'm John
Humphrey over here welcome to the real
rejects for today we're going to watch a
long video about our favorite new
cinematic universe the dark universe so
excited definitely things going to work
no concern let's do it IGN 13 facts
about dark universe law awesome it's my
my guess excited
the dark universe has been born that's
the universal cinematic universe based
on its classic monsters from the 30s
first up is the mummy right the director
Alex Kurtzman is one of the key
architects of the dark universe we spoke
to him at length to find out more about
the project and the rules governing its
creation Kurtzman is a life long devoted
fan of universals classic monsters and
while these new movies will be indebted
to the horror tradition we see them as a
genre in their own right I think for me
the thing that defines
Thingiverse monsters as its own genre
you know separate from really even the
hammer monsters and horror film and
flashier films is that you fear the
monster and you fear for the monster and
those original monster films were they
were parented films and they were played
by movie stars who imbued those monsters
with the heartbreak in an agony and the
ethos in an emotion that was specific to
the Universal Monsters I think that
there was a there was a particular scene
for me as a kid that struck me from
Frankenstein and its scene with
Regenstein at the water with the girl
what struck me about that scene is that
she so desperately wanted to connect to
a human being and to be appreciated and
to be loved and and in his desire to
tech didn't realize he was destroying
the very thing that he wanted to connect
with and that's to me symbolizes the
monsters are about yeah you ask a
four-year-old kid to draw Frankenstein
and they're going to draw green skin and
flattop head and bolts on the neck and
that's the Universal Monsters
Frankenstein
and so for almost 100 years these
monsters have have endured I think
because they represent something so
human and they won't be messing with the
classic design it sounds like we'll be
seeing happy around that generation
Frankenstein c'mon flora when we started
this we have some amazing artists
working on monster designs and we
started playing together look for words
for the monsters which as an adult to be
able to do that for your job is pretty
much investing in the world we started
you know kind of taking different
designs and playing around with them and
saying well what if we remove this and
once we add that and it became
incredibly clear almost instantaneously
that we must not touch these monster if
you start messing those things up you
are actually fundamentally betraying
what everybody loves about them we're
going to make adjustments they have to
be story based adjustments you know
there's something about the story that
mandates that we make the adjustment but
you know so do the Bride of Frankenstein
and not have the streets in the air from
the electricity or to do Frankenstein
without the bolts in the neck and you
know would be a fundamental betrayal and
so I think he is it's figuring out how
to really protect and preserve and not
change what is not broken you know while
the idea of a shared universe brings to
mind comic book movies Kurtzman was keen
to point out that the Munsters got me in
first I tend to feel like the best way
to build the universe is to deliver
individual satisfying films and if the
audiences like those films the universal
began to build itself obviously Marvel
did an amazing job starting with iron
man but people forget that the monsters
were the first shared universe
starting with famous Samuels name and
the reason that that worked was because
they'd already done three Frankenstein
films and they'd are gentle movement
films and the eyes loved both characters
they kind of ran out of gas with those
stories I said what are we going to do
what if we put them together and
suddenly a new story was born and it was
actually really exciting to see and that
birthed a million monster crossovers so
the monsters were the first shared new
marching seams behind ripping mommy
thankful yes
Clark I really like the dogs universe is
Nick Fury you'll receive the secret
organization prediction but jackal was
never a cool character in the original
monster movies Chrisman eventually
included jackal for very specific
reasons I tend not to respond to worlds
where a lot of characters are thrown at
me before I have individual
relationships with them so the idea of
bringing dr. Jekyll into the mummy was a
real debate because you don't
intuitively think that Henry Jekyll is
going to be in the mummy so in our
consumption of the film the idea that
Tom's character Nick inadvertently opens
Pandora's box and comes to understand
that the moment exists in a continuum of
gods and monsters and that you know the
moment may be the oldest but there are
many more and there's an organization
and it's been tracking them and
protecting them and hunting them and
doing different you know depending on
the monster it became clear that someone
was going to have to introduce Tom's
character to that world and then you
sort of say okay well it's gotta be
somebody who has his own relationship to
people if I'm describing Tom's character
and I say this is about a man who you
know has good and evil in him he has to
decide which side in life is going to be
on he has a monster potentially lurking
inside of him waiting to explode outward
well I could also be describing Henry
Jekyll and so the idea that Henry is in
the movie because Henry has been where
Nick is going and acts as a mirror to
the next character suddenly allowed us a
real story reason to put him in the film
welcome to the future while they might
be keeping tabs on these monster there's
no exactly clear weather prediction of
the good guys and that's sort of the
point I think that what's interesting
about the organizations you've got an
organization that is you know as I said
either protecting researching or hunting
monsters run by a man who could be good
or evil you know so it's a somewhat
unpredictable thing even though the
Digium is agenda is ultimately to
protect the world from this whole
existence of monsters there's a kind of
gray area that I think is interesting
and it stays true to what I think the
most
those are about I just don't think
anything is never black and white and in
the Universal Monsters universe while
their intentions are good I think
sometimes you have to do really bad and
scary things to serve a greater good and
maybe provision will be an obsession
it takes a long time to defeat the
overarching threat is also less than
clear right now it's definitely not as
simple as then fight in the monsters we
add curtain it was indeed a big bad it's
a very spoiled rich question you're
asking me I can say this the threat
could come from within tradition there
might be other forces out there are
other organizations that wants to be I
announce to the gym and maybe those
organizations were built on and work on
maybe the monsters don't all have the
same agendas ever they want very
different things maybe someone to bring
the evil into the world while others
want to protect the world from it so I
think you know if you look back at the
original monster films all the monsters
actually did want different things you
know and that's that's the juice that's
where you get your conflict despite a
lot of the original films they can play
predominantly in London and a mythic
version of Europe the dark universe will
be a globe fight franchise these are
global films so it's going to be
dependent on the nature of each monster
yes I am is under the month you could
you had luck with doing exams on you
know so it's all about figuring out what
is the nature of the mythology of each
month start figuring out a setting but
our whole design is to make these global
films even though there's more movies
and characters set up there isn't a TV
for the next installment of the dot
universe at the end of the mummy and
don't expect any in the future
I bet no that's a marvel so mate maybe
it'll feel a more appropriate down the
line at the university itself but I
don't think any of us wanted to be
accused of ripping off what they did so
well Kurtzman says he wants to attract
the best actors to play the monster and
he thinks it's a more attractive
proposition than any superhero role if
you ask any of the actors that we've now
got into the universe Johnny Depp the
air Russell Tom they will all tell you a
similar story about watching the
Universal Monsters as kids and being
terrified and how much they love them
look at it from their point of view okay
you can play superhero in fear
bah camp squared odds are zero well as
they're interesting but often not wildly
deep or you can play a character in
which the assumption is that the
character will be broken damaged violent
upset scary and there's an expectation
that the character will be fixed by the
end because they were fixed they
wouldn't be monsters anymore it's a very
very intimate idea for an actor you know
if you're making movies at the studio
level of the scope and scale how often
you get the chance to make a movie about
complicated gray areas Johnny Depp has
been announced as the Invisible Man but
there's no sound alone film on the car
in yet so we ask they will debut in
Bride of Frankenstein you know picture
technically well that's probably a yes
nth bill condon will direct Bride of
Frankenstein he's the man behind 1988
gods and monsters a biopic of James
Whale director of universals original
Frankenstein and a conclusion is
currently scouting potential directors
we are what you're looking for
obviously fandom as a future part of it
you know so let's take Bill Condon
constructing by a Frankenstein's you're
talking about a director who understands
the nature of what it means to make a
monster movie at the DNA level but also
what those months are represented to
that director I like James Webb this
connection on affinity for Bryce in the
way he represented her and the way you
represented Frankenstein and gods and
monsters told all of us there wasn't
even a debate you know about who should
be directing this movie and because
you're talking about someone who just in
their DNA understands it I think that
it's all about figuring out who speaks
to the spirit of these homes who
understands them the most and which
writers come up with takes that are and
we work with the writers to do that that
are honoring the tradition and the
heritage while bringing something to the
table and it's it's hard you know I mean
we don't want to make these movies until
they're worth making and so they're
right home or on the subject with golden
monsters it's a line upset by dr.
Pretorius in bright a Frankenstein to a
new room
gods and monsters it crops up in the
mummy and Kurtzman stay with our own
design there's something about the
phrase that seems to carry more
significant for this fledgling universe
or it depends on how you interpret
regard I mean you know the Egyptians
interpreted in regard but as Henry says
evil as many names except for example
known to Egyptians of the god of chaos
whereas other cultures called this
without really we're all talking about
the devil I think the idea would be that
we all every culture has a way of
translating the mythology and sometimes
we call them God and sometimes we call
the monsters and I think as the universe
expands we will begin to understand what
that is me I think it will please you
may not even party time and even though
the mummy isn't a full-blown horror
movie Kristen wants the dark universe
the Porsche skates as much as possible
the movies that I loved growing up where
the movies that walked right up to the
line of our you know where you feel like
you're you know you're they hold you in
that state of suspense and terror but
they don't always cross it obviously the
most notable example being you know
seeing Raiders of the Kid and it's just
that's a really scary movie you know and
as a horse of the guy's face melts at
the any like what you know at eight
years old that's shocking but it's you
know it's so appropriate to the story oh
thanks for that oh yeah what I
appreciated alex kurtzman he seems to
have a really in-depth and articulate
way of expressing you know understanding
of what makes the dark University
original dark universe of the other
Universal Monsters work so well it's he
the shepherd of yeah it's new thing like
beyond just the money okay honestly like
if I if I had seen this first yeah I
might have had more hug I really liked
what he had to say yeah it's so weird I
think he's got the right idea and he
seems to understand you know and he
seems to care about these characters and
then these films the advertising just
don't I keep the advertising
doesn't seem to replicate at all or you
know channel Leiden in the same way of
how he's talking about him here yeah you
know I know some people who saw the
mummy already really and they were like
Torben action-comedy hey why and all the
people who said that I mean that's just
a few people yeah I can't take their
word for it but the clips that I did see
seem to have like an action comedy
elements to it you know he's saying
stuff like he doesn't you know they want
to honor the original designs and then I
see sofia boutella in the mummy I'm like
thank the mummy that's the last thing
from the moment yeah yeah yeah I mean
like a few bandages equate to honour
English is the height didn't like that's
not the same thing
you should only sproutin for eyes and
she's doing all sorts of yeah totally
different mummy I like her like I'm I am
open to seeing what they do with the
bidet I was like that looks like a
different mummy yeah yeah not look good
it's a mom and he's talking about how
universes will make some good is when
you make good just solo individual films
you're not pushing
hello universe building when I'm when
the marketing seems to contradict that
completely yeah a lot of getting seems
to be all about the universe building
and about the potential and they all
crossover lately yeah it's all about
because is that's when I find myself
wishing is I am concerned to them
because they're like okay we're doing
this mummy movie and you know rumors
start to spread and just the words the
streak with yet I'm going to do a bunch
of these we're going to revitalize them
and then they came out gung-ho like a
couple weeks ago like this is the
universe here or our plan yeah you look
back to Iron Man I don't remember what
all the announcements and plans were at
that time but I got the sense that Iron
Man was Iron Man and then that was
successful and then we really ramped up
on like okay this is gonna work and I
feel like I'm a little worried they're
putting the cart before the horse too
pissed and being like check out our
universe before we even know the book
one successful yeah yeah exactly and
like I've seen in a herd plan to
cancelled and changed around so much I'm
like this is a gamble and it's not
tracking as
comfortably as they would like to and in
terms of you know it's curtains the one
of the riders who has worked on a lot of
things in about twists and mystery
transformers and rapture ghettos and Tom
Cruise is featured on like the dark
universe like the picture they show that
they show here the hobby of our dam
giant a soapy patella yeah Frank is
denying no other people dance The Mummy
Nick yeah no acknowledge you sofia
boutella is good name and i don't know
why because it's like they're talking
about the monster Ilyn they're talking
about the monsters the trailer showing
Sophie would tell the mummy and no one's
even acknowledging so whoever tells the
mummy you're talking about the Nick guy
that song turns this playing she's the
title care so if you were leading with
her it kind of gets me curious as to you
know like the way he was talking about
who this Nick character is got me more
entry I'm hoping by the time I see the
movie that I'm like oh he is and it's
his own way some type of monster in some
fashion like maybe there's some twist he
has up his sleeve of who Tom Cruise
really is that he's not just a Navy SEAL
Nick dude that he's something much more
and the trailers seem to semi hint at
that you know and it's my baby super in
some way a few weeks oh it was bloody
burying like because or they're dead a
bad corner oh yeah he should be dead he
doesn't look injured at all my wakes up
in that body bag and he's talking about
how dr. Jekyll was in the position that
Tom Cruise's character is at and I
appreciate a way he said of why he
included dr. Jekyll again it looks like
you said if you just showed me this I
would actually be really really
intrigued and that I don't know the
whole Tom Cruise thing hearing that
almost I don't know how to feel about
that idea of what Tom Cruise's something
more because now on the little words is
going to become like Tom Cruise is
basically a superhero these will be
basically like super villains yeah and
here we get talking about like getting
the best actors in but the big rumor
it's just a rumor the big rumor seems to
be for the Wolfman to be Dwayne Johnson
and I'm like that's not the same caliber
of actors that you're talking about here
you know I mean as much as a loved'
actor perhaps right now but yet I
haven't seen him turn in the kind of
performances the rest
yeah it seems like a lot of marketing
seems to be contradicting what he's
saying here yeah hot oven times you know
it's like Alex Kurtzman might be the one
chef man I like being the Shepherd for
this however he's not the one in charge
of all the shots he's not he might be
the one who the creative guy but
universal at the end of the day they
will push their agenda yeah and then
this field yeah it's just it feels
contradictory if this drop the week the
movies supposed to come out it feels
like an attempt to save space we're
having or to be like no no no no no no
people who actually care about the
original movies we care about the to see
now like the more stuff I've seen from
this more things I've heard the less I
understand what is truly going to happen
yeah the more like I'm weirdly intrigued
because in the back of my mind like I
want it to work and especially an
occurred in him talk like I like pretty
much everything he understands it's
weird it seems to have a very deep
understanding of what the universal
monsters are yeah he they're changing
the genre and they practically admitted
to that like the enemy is not really
horror
it's like has elements and he said they
said something like that here yeah yeah
yeah where it's you know it's
action-adventure with some horror
elements and they're saying down the
road they want to push the envelope a
little more but why not just start off
with oh yeah why don't you start off by
being distinctive yeah it's and again we
haven't seen it but like every time I
see those those scenes in the trailer
that look like they're from the third
active movie like I've seen this third
actor whine yeah yeah definitely
The Mummy movies from the 90s and the
early 2000s are our action adventures
with you know a half the amount of
horror Walter it's not hard to put
horror wallpaper in and I feel like
these movies should have some horror
intrinsically in their DNA instead of
distressing up and horror costumes we
should watch it this weekend we probably
said because they retreat watch because
we've got so much about it and there's
so much to do yeah and I don't know for
me I feel like I I ate my duty to go and
at least take a look I don't think we've
ever even been accused in like a hater
comment of having preconceived notions
and then leading our opinion of the
movie off preconceived notions i credit
us as being good at taking the product
the product for what it is
yes this movie wins me over cool yeah
like a and I would like really what I
want is for that to happen yeah
especially here if anything that I'm
hoping that I oh you know what it's way
better than I anticipated yeah I'm
seeing this video I'm like okay if you
are the Shepherd that makes me happy I
like your ideas and so if those wind up
on screen but oftentimes intention
doesn't equate to execution yeah exactly
and yeah I don't know yeah I definitely
want to like this like I said I will you
didn't intention does not a priori so
it's okay laughter use it when it sounds
super smarter I'm like I think I said
that really well you know my friends
you're a very sharp cookies yeah Dwayne
Johnson who's gonna play again I'm like
I mean that's just a rumor
he hasn't been cast yet officially I bet
it's true like that that contradicts a
lot of what's being sent here to because
Dwayne Johnson is a granite superstar
wonderful performer and and I was not
entertaining but he's not on the caliber
of these great actors that you're
talking about no he's not he's he's not
the only way that would work for me like
just just conceptually anyways like if
we had one of those arguments was like
that's weird casting and then he turns
up and he gives us something I haven't
seen him do before and again I would be
very open to that I like doing Johnson
and if he'd wanted to actually throw
down on acting like you know the acting
chops of it and get into the horror side
of it like that would that I would be
down by that I feel like the most
important element of this is the
spiritual element because there's so
much history and stuff to draw from and
this communicates to me that the spirit
is intact everything I've seen out of
the actual movie doesn't do that it
makes me worried for the spirit or looks
like a thrill ride yeah when you're
talking about it the dart will makes the
OG monsters work because that's her
character driven yeah when I'm like man
everything is showing me though from
just The Mummy alone does not does not
seem like and I know it's just trailers
you can't judge it off of that alone
yeah maybe they want to pitch it like
that but it's
like the whole thing is yeah that could
be the case advertising's weird
however it's like you know you got three
different you have to retrain this at
all have a very similar feel and I'd be
very surprised if it's not at all and
come with it how would any of the
trailers are but if that's the case if I
walked out going you know what Alex
Kurtzman he did exactly what he was
setting out to do and he succeeded I'll
be like I'll get on yeah I'll be very
happy and I want to believe you it's
something you know if I were to make a
prediction how I'm going to feel but in
of watching The Mummy I feel like I'm
gonna walk out going it's not as bad as
I thought it would be but it's still not
great that's like that's where I think
I'm gonna land I feel like I'm gonna
walk out going you know it doesn't
exactly live up to everything Alex
Kurtzman saying this video that we saw
however it's not as it's not it's not
like a level of disappointment that you
know like the trailers have been making
me feel like I'll probably land and we
can work from here at the end there's
one thing that I do feel reassured by
now that we've had such as as you see no
babies is a you can we can defeat that
yeah you can go listen to feedback and
you can change things yeah yeah exactly
I do and then you know things can get
better and if you're going to do a
universe hey cool yes and last note we
said in a video last week that we might
be doing a retro review sir is the mummy
and we were going to then we realized
you know we do that it'll be much harder
to just accept what this mummy is it's
such as own thing that if we go in with
like the feeling and the love that we
already know we have for the other mummy
films and then we go in just trying to
adjust and accept this new thing that's
when preconceived notions can really
play a factor in your viewing experience
yeah and we don't want that to happen
when we go watch this movie we want to
make sure that we're able to go in we
know we love if you want a short review
short retro review we love the mummy the
og one and we love the Brendan Fraser
the first two ones don't like the third
one that's not for you
I mean I might be tempted to go back and
watch like the old old mummy like yeah
because that's what they're talking
about yeah yeah they're talking about
the Boris Karloff's like that's the
that's the arrow they're honoring it at
time see I don't want I don't ya
wouldn't want to Brendan Fraser why
because this looks a little too close to
that and like the original the old mummy
is is it this is not a swashbuckler I
know I know I'm not at all and so I
might be interested to go back and
re-watch that maybe if this train
continued and the next one's come out
maybe we will go back and do like the
old Frankenstein the old Wolfman the old
answer from the Black Lagoon I think
right now we just got to see this
ciarán for what it is when you when you
go and watch a movie with the you know
the original in mind so strong it can it
can affect your viewing experience oh
yeah what they're trying to do with own
thing well actually like most as I like
the way we did to kind of appear behind
the curtains I kind of like the way we
do it a lot of times with these movies
that have a lot of material preceding
them is I know you like to go back and
re-watch them all and I usually prefer
to going cold yeah you know so I feel
like we have both of the corners covered
there but this this one since there's so
much around it I feel like cold is is
kind of the best way to go all right
guys well thanks for tuning in to the
channel we are no more service than we
were like and that's just a little more
commute you can subscribe to the real
rejects click that notification that
will be notified every time one of our
videos is up John is that John Humphrey
on Twitter and Instagram social media
manager at bloom house calm and you can
go check out our patreon for exclusive
purse on there the rewards the exclusive
video content that we have there hugs
hugs go check it out have a great time
guys and keep a look out for our review
of the mummy that'll be at some point
this weekend I don't know if we're gonna
I don't think we're going to go Thursday
night I don't care that money you're not
gonna lose sleep yeah over by Sunday
it'll be